[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide I'm currently packing all my
things getting ready for Sundance that's
where I'll be in next week's episode but
before I go there are a couple of films
out in theaters that I want to draw your
attention to the first one is a
detective story which feels like a
classic crime caper mixed with a touch
of modern-day Coen brothers and
Tarantino most mornings I'm about as
worthless as a park bench in hell
usually don't start thinking straight
till you get a couple cold ones in me it
also feels very original this is called
small town crime and it's directed by
two other brothers ischium and iam Nelms
and stars John Hawkes and Octavia
Spencer and Hawkes plays a former cop
who's now struggling with alcohol and he
gets involved with a murder plot you
shouldn't be fiddling around with some
dead girl's bone I think what Kelly is
trying to say is that you are no longer
a cop don't tell me what I'm trying to
say it's crackling and it shows just how
skilled Octavia and John are at their
craft blend of a finish my beer you
drunk I'm comfortable
small-town crime is a fantastic gritty
thriller that satisfying and shows that
you don't need a huge budget to keep an
audience engaged it's available from
this weekend in limited theaters is that
blood in there yeah it's gonna be extra
also this weekend two films which are
both awards contenders come out wide so
that means more people can see them
let's start with phantom thread I've
been looking for you for a very long
time this is of course directed by Paul
Thomas Anderson and features Daniel
day-lewis as a fashion designer in the
1950s who uses women as muses but there
is one woman who refuses to go easily
there is an air of quiet death in this
house you're not cursed you're loved by
me stop playing this game what game what
precisely is the nature of my game this
is a twisted romance but more of a
comedy than you may expect and it's a
nice swan song for Daniel day-lewis who
says he's going to retire you can see
phantom thread available in even more
theaters from this weekend and make sure
you see I Tanya which is also going wide
this weekend this does Margot Robbie as
Tonya Harding it is a biopic of sorts it
touches on that whole incident with
Nancy Kerrigan and it's a dark comedy
with Allison Janney who plays Tonya
Harding's mother when I was a kid did
you ever love me I made you a champion
no one you'd hate me for it that's the
sacrifice a mother makes to cursed me I
know some people have struggled with the
tone of this movie because it does talk
about some very serious things like
domestic assault and it does it in
almost a comedic way but I particularly
love the way that they use Tonya
Harding's story to speak about America
in general and the culture of celebrity
there's lots going on here and a great
performance by Margot Robbie see I Tanya
in more theaters from this weekend and
on Fandango now one to watch at home is
loving Vincent this is an animated
that has already been nominated for
awards I'm sure it'll be up for an Oscar
as well
directed by Dorota Kabila and Hugh
Welshman this is a detective type story
delving into the mysteries surrounding
the death of Vincent van Gogh it does
this via a fictional tale of a man who
needed to deliver a letter to Vincent I
don't see the point in delivering a dead
man's letter so if you had died and
there was a letter out there that you
had sent to me I want us the most
impressive thing about this film is the
animation and it will make your jaw drop
each frame is hand-painted by one of 125
artists who worked on the movie those
artists were chosen from a pool of over
5000 candidates and they painted the
entire film in the style of Vincent this
is a marvelous effect it sucks you into
the film and makes you appreciate even
more the unique talent of Van Gogh
loving Vincent is definitely worth
checking out on Fandango now it's there
right now for you to watch I would like
to show by my work what this nobody has
in his heart
[Music]
you're loving Vincent that's what I
recommend to watch this weekend next
week as I mentioned I'll be at the
Sundance Film Festival so I'll take you
along for the journey and I'll let you
know about all the films that I've been
watching until then
[Music]